rendre le yoga plus visible c'est
l'objectif à montigny le bretonneux le
24 juin
c'était journée découverte au centre
pierre de coubertin deux associations de
yoga ont accueilli les adeptes d'un jour
90 personnes pour s'initier gratuitement
à l'activité
c'est la deuxième journée que nous ans
que nous organisons à montigny depuis
l'année dernière c'est un moyen de faire
connaître de yoga à un plus grand
population une deuxième journée
internationale du yoga montini sous
l'égide de l'ambassade indienne l'inde
est le pays d'origine du yoga il y
occupe toujours une place très
importante
nba en inde c'est un mode de vie par
mode de vie j'entends une pratique
complète qui s'insère dans notre façon
de vivre
quand nous sommes à bout fatigue est
incapable d'être attentif nous
concentrons sur le souffle nous faisons
du yoga c'est notre moyen pour être
tranquille détente musculaire meilleure
gestion des émotions le yoga semble
séduire en france mais ne fait pas du
yoga qui veut patience régularité
encadrement sont nécessaires pour cette
activité
si le yoga procurent des bienfaits il
reste d'abord sport exigeant en fait
le yoga est bon pour le dos maintenant
quand il ya des blessures quand il y a
les hernies discales des douleurs
chroniques
on demande de toute façon pour la
pratique toujours un certificat médical
c'est important et puis après ben c'est
aussi au port aux personnes de respecter
leurs limites c'est à dire que le yoga
s'adapte à la personne et non l inverse
vu le succès rencontré cette année les
organisateurs pourraient de nouveau
organisé une journée de ce type l'an
prochain